yeah are we really permitted as a
legitimate for ordinary folks to use
that word evil because it tended for
thousands of years to belong to the
sphere of religion and philosophy but I
notice as we all do that people use the
word evil all the time people in
ordinary life journalist prosecutors
judges etc so I began to create a scale
of evil I ended up at first with just a
few numbers on my scale but I then got
it up to twenty-two of which the first
one was not evil just justified homicide
number two was crimes of passion all the
way up to 22 where there was usually a
serial killer subjecting victims to
prolong torture and you could divide
that into three main segments one of
which was for impulsive murders by
people who really were not psycho-pass
they were not the kind of persons who do
unspeakable things all the time
routinely and have absolutely no remorse
and they're totally hard-hearted and
callous ordinary people that get caught
in some terrible situation for example
and then the next bunch of numbers from
let's say around nine to sixteen are for
people that show a fair number of
psychopathic traits those being
grandiosity and superficial charm and
glibness and manipulative Ness and lying
and lack of remorse and callousness and
so on and then finally you get to people
who are clearly psychopathic by all the
modern definitions especially these
serial killers and the ones that go in
for prolonged torture